et on va analyser ce sondage crop radio
canada avec un 10 ans sont luc ferrandez
bon choix bonsoir
première éléments que je vais vous
montrer intéressant parce que le taux de
participation municipale
quarante deux pour cent la dernière fois
à montréal
43 l'autre fois d'avant 39 avant avant
avant c'est pas c'est pas beaucoup or
regardez le premier tableau qu on pose
la question aux gens avez vous
l'intention d'aller voter à la prochaine
élection municipale y en a 60 8% qui
disent oui
qu'est ce que ça vient c'est que c'est
un voeu pieux qu'on se dit on aimerait
qu'on y passe pour anny bey on est gêné
dire qu'on y repas donc 18 facilement
mais on le voit dans les résultats le
pille on le sent sur le terrain le si on
atteint 35 ans 35 et 40 là ça va être un
beau une belle réussite de toute
participation cette année en 35 et 40
vous dites gens qui ont subi ce temps là
bas on le voit on le voit sur le terrain
les gens sont peu intéressés ils en
parlent peau quand on leur dit
connaissez vous ment ça nous intéresse
pas qui pourtant je le dis encore le
milieu municipal et celui qui est le
plus important et souvent on dit ben les
les citoyens méritent les élus qu'ils
ont donc ceux qui n'ont pas voté à
procès se permettre de critiquer quand
quand tu participes à barrett pas droit
au chapitre qu'est-ce qu'on fait le même
constat et vous promener à vélo dans les
dans votre ville les gens s'intéressent
moins la campagne quoi dans les
quartiers centraux il ya eu une grosse
le gros intérêt lomé mais c'est
impossible d'avoir un tel taux de
participation qui était le taux
d'indécis en même temps le taux d'aidé
si on va voir plus loin il est très très
élevé a déjà quitté je vais absolument
voter mais je sais pas pour qui voter ça
c'est rare bon alors par lonza voyons le
tableau pour quel candidat sur les vous
tentés de voter intentions de vote donc
denis coderre on le place à 26 et madame
plantes à 25 et monsieur on est et à 5
pour ça et on va le voir les indécis à
27,7 énorme donc égalité statistique
entre les deux meneurs on va voir le
tableau
oui année à égalité statistique cela
vous surprend pas non non pas du tout
moi je vous l'avais dit depuis le début
que pour moi je parierais même pas un
dollar aujourd'hui là je voudrais
histoire du vote mais il y est c'est
trop c'est trop instable et on regarde
aussi la clientèle les deux ont des
clientèles totalement différente mais là
qu'elle va aller voter le gros défi
devait les replays hamon à mon humble
avis puis tu pourras peut-être la dir
l'ucl mais c'est que sa clientèle ses 18
34 ans et des 18-34 ans et un de 25 %
qui vont voter la clientèle de denis
coderre sim clientèle plus mature plus
élevé plus vieille se love on voit tes
mais là avec un taux de participation
comme ça reste à voir comment les
prochains débats vont peut-être faire la
différence on voit les chiffres le lieu
que
c'est ça c'est qui va aller voter c'est
ça la clé bon ben ça c'est par est en
train de changer effectivement
historiquement ça toujours été des
personnes plus âgées qui votait et les
personnes plus âgées votre pour monsieur
coderre sauf que pour les enjeux de
vélos et les enjeux d'environnement qui
sont en croissance on ne voit que dans
un tableau plus loin on va voir que ya
12 pour cent d'appuis à l'environnement
autant que la mobilité là autant que les
questions de congestion au taquet
question développement économique et
donc je pense que cette clientèle
l'europe est peut-être en train de
changer d'histoire et dire nous on va
aller voter même si on est jeunes puis
ça nous intéresse à suivre je peux je
pose une hypothèse une hypothèse bon
faire un show rapide dans l'est dans les
deux autres villes importantes de la
région longueuil et laval longueuil
d'abord on va voir le tableau catherine
fournier qui semble voguer à 33% vers
une victoire à nice avec ses chefs le
jeu pourrait parier quelque chose là
mais oui effectivement le chemin tracé
mais encore une fois 44% d'un dc mais la
différence entre elle et les autres elle
est quand même énorme donc le 40% à 1
d'ici là dessus je vous dirais j'ai pas
beaucoup de risques là madame fourni
pour l'instant si si pas d'erreur en
cours de route c'est bien la surprise
shannon c'est peut-être que jacques
létourneau qui avait quand même une
notoriété mais peut-être dans le grand
public - il est à 4 difficile à
expliquer parce que il ya des bonnes
idées de son côté comme dans les autres
aussi ce qui semble se passer c'est un
phénomène qu'on avait avec mélanie joly
à montréal elle s'était présentée elle
n'avait pas l'expérience municipal paul
était passé elle avait presque
gagné c'était en 2009 et la madame
fournit un peu le même le même
positionnement mais en plus elle a été
elle a été députée péquiste avait été
députée indépendante avait quitté le
parti québécois parce que jugé qu'il
avance est passé rapidement sur la
question d'indépendance mais aussi elle
a fait des alliances avec huit autres
jeunes femmes dès le départ de sa
campagne puis après avec le maire de
laval elle est très active
dynamisme et qui risque d'être mais
reste donc le le 7 novembre soit bon
lavalin rapidement l'aval si on peut
mettre le tableau je bois y est
si serré elle avale les trois premiers
14 11 hommes je voyais que ce trentième
l'autre monsieur trottier
difficile à prévoir le dauphin est en
avance un plan le dauphin est en avance
si tu me permets 56 % d'indécis et au
niveau de satisfaction on va le voir
plus tard les gens sont satisfaits de
justement du dauphin de ce que marc
demers a fait donc les gens sont
principalement satisfaits du service
donc ça peut donner des jolies les unes
idée mais c'est quand même a commencé
ring puisque puis encore 2 56% et d'ici
là comme 6 la campagne intéresser les
gens dit je vais nous savons donc si on
veut pas en entendre parler c'est quand
même impressionnant ce sont des bons
candidats ici il se distingue sur
certaines idées
le fait que ya peine 14% à 11 pour ça
c'est des chiffres misérables c'est
vraiment ça témoin d'un désintérêt pour
la politique d'autres lots exactement il
ça peut être inquiétant pour la suite
des choses on verra les taux de
participation dimanche dans deux
semaines bon on a parlé c'est toujours
important le prochain tableau le taux de
satisfaction à l'endroit l'inspiration
place jacquard mais elle a 48 % d'appuis
deux des montréalais et 22 17 c'est
quand même énorme l'ucla bon ça c'est le
tableau qu'il n'est plus surprenant
c'est à dire qu'avec un taux de
satisfaction comme celui là avec un bon
bilan bilan kobe bryant économique et
cetera comment ça se fait qu'elle
n'arrive pas à monter à ce moment ci de
la campagne moi je me serais attendu à
ce cas le monde j'ai deux hypothèses la
première hypothèse c'est que il y aurait
une grande plus la tente sur la question
bon vélo congestion voiture travaux et
la deuxième hypothèse ce sera une
question de personnalité peut-être
qu'ils ne passent pas la troisième
hypothèse c'est peut-être que il était
possible pour un parti de gauche plutôt
progressiste de faire plus que 30% ça
prend une élection à 3 pour que partie
gauche progresser se passe hélas va
falloir que je travaille très très fort
pour gagner
annie qu'est ce que ça vous dit aussi
passé quand même étonnant les gens sont
la moitié sont satisfaits la moitié sont
satisfaits mais l'autre moitié il l'est
pas ou beaucoup c'est comme entre les
deux il faut trouver faut que les
chiffres se balance je vous le dis c'est
tout va se jouer dans le dernier sprint
les trois prochaines semaines c'est
l'eau quand les gens vont vraiment là se
positionner parce que de façon ordinands
les gens sont satisfaits du travail que
le fait si on regarde longueuil et laval
on parle tant d'autres ce tantôt laval
65 % des gens sont satisfaits de ce que
l'administration de mire ce fait et à
longueuil 50 pour ça donc c'est comme un
geste non c'était c'est énorme je vais
vous montrer l'autre tableau c'est
intéressant sur les enjeux là est ce que
c'est parce qu'on a par davantage dans
les médias la sécurité arrive en premier
à 26 % des gens qui disent un enjeu qui
devrait être la priorité accès au
logement ça c'est pas surprenant
avec la crise du logement mobilité c'est
plus loin derrière on parlait que de ça
la dernière fois 15% relance économique
et la place du français huit
environnements vous n'avez pas de compte
à vouziers les justes 12 non je sais sur
gan de 12 des pas contents mais si tu
regardes par rapport en comparaison par
exemple que la relance économique que la
mobilité des thèmes dont on parle tous
les jours dans les médias c'est à peu
près équivalent donc la grèce ça
progresse c'est ainsi quand on regarde
par exemple sur des questions précises
est ce que vous êtes intéressé à fermer
le centre-ville aux voitures un appui de
59 pour ça ça c'est extraordinaire donc
on voit que ça progresse bon ben
justement annie je vais vous montrer le
tableau puis vous pourrez me parler de
sécurité si vous voulez mais ce mois
j'ai trouvé que c'était je pensais a
voulu quand j'ai vu ce tableau là je
resterai une fortement l'accès aux
véhicules à essence au centre-ville vous
avez dû l'encadré le tableau parce qu'il
ya cinq ans presque 60% des gens qui
disent qu'ils sont en accord avec soi -
une voiture allez-vous-en répondu
annie d'abord votre réaction ça montre
que encore une fois ça devrait nous dire
que madame plan sera en avance mais je
vous dirais que là dedans dans ce
tableau laussucq sont d'accord donc on
parle avec près de 60% le sait les 18 54
ans majoritairement ceux qui ont aucune
voiture est drôlement les hommes puis si
on regarde ceux qui sont en désaccord
ben et c'est l'essai l'ouest de la ville
parce que le ce qui était d'accord issu
du centre donc là c'est l'ouest son
compte des 55 ans et plus femme
sait déjà c'est bizarre c'est bizarre
mais c'est vrai que ceux qui restent
dans le centre parce que c'est ce centre
qui reçoit toutes les voitures c'est
tout à fait normal qu'on en parle
chaleur qu'un moulin bombe passée ce que
vous avez essayé de faire chez vous oui
et puis la piétonnisation de la rue
mcgill qui va devenir une grande place
publique le retrait du stationnement sur
sainte-catherine pour faire des grands
trottoirs la multiplication des places
publiques ça peut faire un centre-ville
extrêmement intéressant les gens sont
conscients et annie a raison de dire
pour regarder qui va au centre et c'est
pas tout le monde qui va au centre-ville
là les gens veulent utiliser leur
voiture quand son amie katy un peu plus
excentré mais comprennent même ceux qui
ont des voitures même ceux qui aiment
être en voiture qu'à vers le centre
ville le stationnement de plus en plus
cher de plus en plus rares l'expérience
pour les piétons est excellente
peut-être que c'est en train de changer
et leur m2 laisse on a beaucoup parlé
puis pas toujours en termes très
élogieux il ya eu tous ces gens qui ont
écrit dans les journaux le voulez vous
étiez de sulky dealer
je suis très critique mais le chiffre 60
4 existe 77 % des gens très favorable ou
assez favorables à ce projet là puis
plus tard on n'a pas un tableau mais
j'en dise il ya une majorité qui dit
nous qui soit en haut ou en bas ça nous
importe moins quand même année un appui
pour l'europe de l'est forts mais très
fort ces chiffres parlent pour moi c'est
pour moi c'est très parlant et on parle
de 68 67 pour ça mais sa vie encore
qu'ils sont les premiers appuyant ces
légendes du centre et ceux qui sont les
plus négatifs c'est les gens de l'ouest
a essayé de comprendre l'ouest ils l'ont
mais ils veulent pas que les cela et
c'est ce que j'ai semblé comprendre
c'est toujours les 18-24 18 34 ans qui
sont d'accord avec le real peu importe
en haut ou en bas c'est des gens qui
n'ont pas de voitures principalement et
c'est surtout ça c'est surprenant il me
met dans l'eure dans le sondage les
revenus des gens et ce sont les gens qui
ont 80 mg et les plus sont d'accord avec
leur m dans la majorité le 2 et des
lignes le sondage conclusion le dessus
c'est un projet extraordinaire en terme
de mobilité le savent a connecté laisse
sa place au 10 minutes ça va me
connecter le laisse avec le centre ville
mais aussi avec l'universel moral est
aussi avec l'aéroport de montréal c'est
un projet de transport en commun
extraordinaire le problème y est il est
sur certains éléments du parcours en
particulier rené lévesque laisse un
énorme trou dans la vue peut-être que
les gens peuvent visualiser sauf
peut-être qu'ils viennent pas souvent en
centre-ville non plus notre court terme
de transport en commun est un beau
projet et si ce pourquoi ils votent
schmolz bien le 15 pour 5 sont
défavorables seulement donc sa lettre le
projet durable merci à vous deux donc
tour d'horizon de ce sondage et enverra
le 7 novembre qui rend voter combien de
gens iront voter parce qu'il ya qu'il ya
quand même une tendance inquiétante de
ce côté là sur les différents mais
peut-être aussi l'élection fédérale a
pas aidés là une fatigue
vous en parlait alors très bien merci
beaucoup